As always, it's a good idea to look into equilibria, to understand what's happening.
Most probably the time constant that governs the burning of wood
is much higher than the time constant that's responsible for the heat loss.
Heat loss will be quicker than burning.
We can safely assume that the density of the wood is almost constant
on the time scale on which the temperature develops, and now we can draw this nice diagram
that shows how the rate of change of the temperature depends on temperature.
If we are below ignition, we only have heat loss. That's the linear function with negative slope.
And when the temperature equals the ambient temperature, the rate of change will be zero.
So that's this part of the curve.
A linear function with negative slope and that function is zero at the ambient temperature,
and the second regime, when there is combustion, we have to add this constant.
And as we assume that the density of the wood stays almost constant,
the burn rate is almost constant.
What we get is simply a shift upwards.
The same linear function as before but shifted upward like this.
Now, here's a question for you--how many stable equilibria do you see here. Enter that number.